Bình bị đêm mọi người mùng chiến thuyên một dưới địa phương,
tất trường ngày mùng môi thêm một dưới hành động đã bỏ víu thông qua bước thủ thủ quan trọng.
Dúc mờ lại chính cụ liên bán sau đủ môn mấy ngày tế liệt.
Trăm rất tròi ngày chính cụ đồng cửa giải nhất trong lịch sử dụng nữa Mỹ.
Dữ luật trước đó đã được học hiện thông qua,
cùng các ngăn sách tạm thời cho chính cụ hả động,
lĩnh ngày bán môi tham một năm 2020,
đông thời góp bà đã luật chi tiêu trọng năm,
cho các cụ của liên bán.
Cô bỏ biểu đặt sống mứa trở thận tại thử viện vừa đủ để được thông qua.
Cũng theo thật đặt được sông dựa gần thương lượng.
Đàn cộng hoa chất thật tổ chức một cuộc bỏ tiêu dương trong thống Mỹ 2,
nhằm ra hành cá khoảng trở cấp i tế theo trường trình của bà mà kê,
vốn lệ yêu cầu thành chốt của phay dần chủ.
Dữ luật cụ quy định tạm dừng các đường xa thả những viên bán đến hết thả một năm 2020,
đàn bảo trả lương và cóc lại trở cấp thức phẩm cho hơn 2 chựa cộng chức.
Mà gồm con nhớn, nhớn bên phòng và kìm sốt bên phòng liệu.
Tổn thủ đúng năng tròm đả hoang gần tế chế này,
sông tế tục kênh vỏ kê thế các khoảng trở cấp bảo hiệ tế,
bằng khoảng chi trực tiếp trường này,
cho rằng hệ thống viện tại chỉ làm dầu cho các công ty bảo hiệm.
Dựa phần tích nhận định dù chính phủ liên bán đả hoa đồng trở lại.
Đưa đông cụ ở dành nhất có thể đã khiến tăng trở kìm tế Mỹ quy bôn,
viện trực lại, đặc biệt trong vồ giú lực bà bô sâm lệ tạ ơn của năm.